a besoin de l'engagement de tous les
siens merci la parole et à madame claude
dray madame la ministre des affaires
sociales et de la santé les français le
savent déjà
l'histoire du mandat de françois
hollande n'a été que mensonges et vous y
avez pris tout de votre part car en
effet comment pouvez-vous décemment dire
que vous avez sauvé la sécurité sociale
ce n'est pas un budget que vous
présentez c'est le maquillage séduisant
d'une situation catastrophique
tout cela est intolérable car ce que
vous dites est faux et pour au moins
trois raisons
vos annonces irresponsables ne masque
pas les augmentation de la csg celle des
cotisations sociales de la diminution de
plusieurs remboursements du reste à
charge du contrat ce soi disant
responsables
la suppression du quotient familial la
mise sous condition de ressources d'un
grand nombre de prestations votre second
mensonge est un tour de passe passe
comptables inacceptable vous vous
autorisez à sortir de votre bilan
le fonds de solidarité vieillesse qui
présente quatre milliards de déficit
pour l'assurance maladie
vous avez décidé de sortir de l'ondam
annuel le coût des médicaments innovants
et ce ne sont que deux exemples
enfin vous vous à vous approprier les
réussites de la précédente majorité
c'est bien la réforme de retraites de
2010 menée par eric woerth qui a sauvé
notre système alors que le vôtre
augmentera les dépenses de 3,2 milliards
d'euros l'année prochaine
sur les déserts médicaux vous n'hésitez
pas à mettre à votre actif les maisons
médicales mises en place par la
précédente mandature
la conclusion tout ceci madame la tour
air c'est que l'addition sera bien payés
par les français et les professionnels
de santé et bien ils sont vent debout
contre le tiers payant généralisé
vous avez enclenché la
déresponsabilisation individuel en
faisant croire que la santé était
gratuite madame touraine votre sentiers
où notre santé n'a pas de prix mais la
santé un coût et les français doivent
savoir que sous le quinquennat de
françois hollande
vous avez augmenté la dette de 50
milliards avec vous elle atteindra 156
milliards
alors êtes vous satisfaite
si la parole est à madame marisol
touraine ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés
je reconnais madame la députée claude
greff votre sens de la mesure et la
finesse d'analysé qui est régulièrement
la vôtre mais madame la députée les
faits sont têtus et les chiffres sont là
le déficit du régime général de la
sécurité sociale sera ramené de 17
milliards et demi d'euros en 2011 à 400
millions d'euros l'année prochaine cela
madame la députée c'est un fait ce sont
des chiffres
elles sont têtus alors je dois dire que
ensuite je ne sais pas comment vous
suivre vous me dit ça n'est pas vrai
mais c'est grâce à nous alors il
faudrait savoir où ça n'est pas vrai ou
c'est grâce à vous alors commençons par
regarder ce qui serait grâce à vous la
réforme de 2010 me dites vous et ce qui
permet l équilibre de la sécurité
sociale la réforme de 2010 a permis
d'apporter des ressources à la sécurité
sociale
elles sont de 11 milliards sur les
années écoulées
au total nous avons par nos réformes
apportées 39 milliards est ce que vous
oubliez de dire c'est que votre réforme
a coûté aux départements puisqu'on a vu
les dépenses de rsa d'invalidité dahache
augmenter et donc ça aussi c'est votre
bilan vous me dites madame la députée
que la dette a augmenté
je vous demande très simplement de
reprendre vos chiffres et de regarder
les textes puisque la dette sociale pour
la première fois depuis l'année dernière
diminue elle était de 148 milliards
d'euros en 2011 elle sera de 140
milliards d'euros c'est beaucoup c'est
aussi la vôtre mais nous avançons madame
la députée nous sommes responsables nous
poursuivons en faveur des droits sociaux
mais vous devriez vous réjouir au lieu
de toujours vouloir être annonciatrice
de mauvaises nouvelles
le déficit de la sécu mode